hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute porzer
das sind teigtaschen und zwar gefüllte
super lecker total soft und dieses
rezept wird euch gefallen dann bin ich
mir sicher ich will in diesem video ein
rezept für den basis teig und drei
füllung zeigen mit denen ich immer
zwischen den videos hin und her switchen
müsst wir machen also wie gesagt den
teig hackfleisch füllung schafskäse
füllung und kartoffel füllung da sind
wohl die drei beliebtesten füllungen und
ich sag jetzt aber zuallererst die
zutaten und die zubereitung des teigs
wir benötigen mehr lauwarme milch
neutrales ölig api rapsöl verwendet
außerdem puderzucker frische hefe
backpulver und salz später zum
bestreichen benötigen wir eigelbe und
etwas milch und nochmal für die deko
entweder schwarzkümmel oder umgerüsteten
sesam oder aber auch gerne geröstetem
sesam für den teilnehmer gibt eine große
schüssel und die lauwarme milch die
kommt jetzt nämlich als allererstes hier
ein die milch darf nicht zu heiß sein
also ungefähr 35 bis 38 grad an ist
perfekt
[Musik]
als nächstes kommt die frische hefe
hinein und ihr merkt dass sie ganz
frisch ist wenn sie so richtig schön
zerbröselt in eurer hand und jetzt geben
wir noch unser puderzucker dazu und
falls ihr euch wundert warum ich
puderzucker verwendet das hat sich unter
anderem in der türkei schon total
etabliert und der teig wird dadurch
einfach fluffige und der schmeckt auch
nicht süß macht euch da keine sorgen
nämlich auflöst dann gebe ich einen
teller drüber und lass das ganze acht
bis zehn minuten lang stehen damit die
hilfe auch wirklich aktiviert werden
kann
während die hilfe jetzt geht kann ich
euch noch mal ganz kurz was zu den maßen
sollen wir haben jetzt zehn nämlich
abmessungen in tasten die flüssigen
zutaten werden in der türkischen küche
oder auch in ganz vielen anderen
meistens durch tasten abgemessen und
nicht durch die waage ich habe jetzt
auch eine tasse genommen die um fast 250
milliliter ihr könnt auch mit kleineren
oder eine größere nehmen aber dann
werdet ihr merken dass sie entweder mehr
oder weniger mehl benötigt für die die
sich nicht ganz so sicher sind schreibe
ich aber die genauen gramm zahlen die
ich ab gemessen habe auch nochmal unten
in die infobox so die zehn minuten sind
um jetzt nämlich einmal den teller ab
und dann können wir das öl mit dazugeben
jesus egal ob jetzt raps oder
sonnenblumenöl verwendet nimmt auf jeden
fall ein neutrales öl olivenöl geht auch
aber das ist schon ein bisschen
intensiver
[Musik]
das wird jetzt kurz miteinander verrührt
und als nächstes geben wir unser mehl
mit dazu aber nicht alles auf einmal
gibt erstmal nur die hälfte dazu dann
backpulver und salz und dann fange ich
erst mal an zu kneten und natürlich geht
es auch mit der küchenmaschine aber mit
den hinten hat man ein besseres gefühl
und ich will euch auch zeigen dass nicht
immer alles mit der küchenmaschine
gemacht werden muss sondern auch ganz
einfach mit den händen funktioniert und
falls sich jetzt ein oder andere
gewundert hat warum ich 2 back trieb
mittel in den teig geben das heißt hefe
und backpulver das gehört sich so der
türkischen küche ist das schon etabliert
und ganz normal und ich empfehle es euch
auch seitlich total ans herz man
schmeckt s nicht raus weder backpulver
noch hefe aber man merkt einfach diesen
fluffigen unterschied also probieren es
aus und teilen euer feedback mit
[Musik]
und es ist ganz wichtig dass ihr das
mehl nun nach und nach mit dazu gibt und
nicht alles gleich auf einmal
denn es kann dann schon sein dass wir
100 km zu viel rein gibt und er zeigt
dann zu festigen und das kann man nicht
mehr rückgängig machen sobald der tag
sich dann einigermaßen verbunden habt
nehmt ihn aus der schüssel und knetet
ihn auf der arbeitsfläche zirka vier bis
fünf minuten lang weiter
wiki-watch fitnessstudio an merck oder
ja machen fortschritte
stimmt die aber sind auf jeden fall
trainiert
[Musik]
und nach fünf minuten ist der teig ganz
fertig ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz
wieder sein muss also erst mal soll das
nun richtig schöne kugel seien keine
risse und wenn ich hier einmal ein
drückt dann ist so ein widerstand was
war jetzt zu machen aber ich sage ich
jetzt mal ganz kurz zu viel mehr übrig
habe etwa 80 gramm ist hier noch übrig
also ich habe auch nicht alles gebraucht
jetzt nehme ich mit zwei schlüsseln teil
den teig nämlich auf schalte ich einmal
in der hälfte durch formen zu einer
kugel und dann lassen wir den in zwei
schüsseln gehen mit etwas mehl
[Musik]
unsere hefeteig werden jetzt mit zwei
küchen tüchern abgedeckt und dann müssen
sie auf zimmertemperatur eine stunde
lang gehen falls jetzt fragte hier kann
ich es ganz am vorabend machen und am
nächsten morgen zum beispiel zum
frühstück backen ist auch kein problem
dann könnt ihr das ganze vorbereiten und
dann im kühlschrank gehen lassen auch
abgedeckt und das ist dann gar kein
problem
während unser teig jetzt geht nutze ich
die zwischenzeit und zeigt euch unsere
drei füllungen die erste die wir zu
bereiten geht schnell und ist super
lecker also mein persönlicher favorit
und zwar ist eine schafskälte füllung
dafür benötigen wir auch mit dieser
beiden zutaten und zwar einmal
schafskäse und fein gehackte petersilie
jetzt nehmen wir uns ganz einfach
unseren schafskäse geben das in eine
schüssel und dann verkleinern wir das
ganze mit der gabel fügen die petersilie
hinzu und dann ist die erste füllung
auch schon fertig
[Musik]
das war die erste füllung und jetzt geht
es weiter mit den leckeren kartoffel
füllungen
dafür benötigen wir gar gekochte und
geschälte kartoffeln außerdem fein
gehackte zwiebeln fein gehackte
petersilie olivenöl knoblauch paprika
markt und an gewürzen salz pfeffer edel
süßes paprikapulver und rosmarin
die gekochten kartoffeln werden jetzt
zuallererst verkleinert aber nicht so
fein dass es für ihr wird sondern so
dass noch einiges stückchen enthalten
sind dafür könnt ihr entweder in
kartoffelstampf an ihm oder auch wieder
eure gabel
[Musik]
die kartoffeln geben wir dann an die
seite und jetzt geht's auf dem herd
weiter jetzt gebe ich zuallererst das
olivenöl in meine geschichte fahne und
dann wird das auf mittlerer stufe
erhitzt und anschließend diensten wir
darin knoblauch und zwiebeln an
[Musik]
nach einer minute geben sie uns auf
paprika marx hinzu und nach einer
weiteren minute dann die gewürze
wer kein caprica mag da hat der kann
auch gerne tomatenmark dem aber ich bin
da steckt noch ein bisschen intensiver
[Musik]
unsere gewürze werden auch nur ganz kurz
mit eingemischt und dann gehen wir den
inhalt der pfanne einmal mit zu unseren
kartoffeln
an der stelle könnt ihr auch nochmals
abschmecken ob genug salz drin ist und
dann gebe ich die klein gehackte
petersilie mit hinzu falls sie die nicht
mögen die die auch ganz einfach
ersatzlos weg lassen
[Musik]
und fertig ist die kartoffel füllung da
muss ich aufpassen dass der hamza nicht
wäre nicht das gefühl alles auf ist denn
er liebt diese füllung und genau wie
geht jetzt an die seite und wir machen
weil sie mit der hackfleisch füllung und
dafür benötigen wir rinder gehacktes
olivenöl fein geschnittene zwiebeln
knoblauch paprika mark und einen
gewürzen salz pfeffer edel süßes
paprikapulver kreuzkümmel und oregano
und hier gehen wir auch wieder so vor
dass wir das öl erhitzen auf mittlerer
stufe zwiebeln und knoblauch hinzu eine
minute lang dünsten und dann wird das
paprika macht ebenfalls eine minute
darin angedünstet
so als nächstes wird das fleisch
angebraten und anschließend gehen wir
die gewürze mit dazu und dann ist die
füllung auch schon fertig
[Musik]
so die würzige hackfleisch füllung ist
auch fertig ich habe dir ganz kurz
umgefüllt und an die seite gegeben und
jetzt machen wir weiter mit unserem tag
der mit zwischenzeit super ausgenutzt
und den tag habe ich hier schon
vorbereitet ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz
meine welchen so und jetzt zeige ich
euch anhand der zweiten hälfte des tages
wie ich das gemacht habe
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir uns den teig aus der
schüssel genommen und ganz kurz nochmal
geknetet graz ein paar sekunden um jetzt
nehme ich mich hier mit so einer
tankkarte ein paar stückchen ab ungefähr
70 gramm golfballgröße und dann wollen
wir das zu kugeln
[Musik]
wichtig ist dass wir die kugeln gleich
noch mal zehn minuten ruhen lassen denn
sie sind auch sehr elastisch und nach
den zehn minuten kann man einfach viel
besser formen wir nehmen uns jetzt auf
unsere arbeitsfläche noch ein bisschen
mehl damit auch nichts an klebt und noch
ein geschirrtuch obendrauf damit die
oberfläche auch nicht trocknet
[Musik]
so ich habe jetzt alle meine entchen
geformt die durften mindestens zehn
minuten ruhen und jetzt die nicht mehr
den ersten wenig gerade geräumt habe und
ich zeige euch jetzt alle drei firmen
mit verschiedenen formen damit wir sie
später unterscheiden können und ich
befehle zuallererst die schafskäse
füllungen und dafür einfach den
teiglingen schön lang und breit
ausrollen
jetzt nehmen wir uns ein esslöffel von
der schafskäse füllung und verteilen ihn
auf den unteren rand des teiges das
ganze jetzt einmal aufrollen und feste
andrücken
[Musik]
sobald man alles schön fest angedrückt
ist schneiden wir hiermit unsere pizza
messer oder dem normalen messe einfach
lange linien und bis zum ende dass die
komplett durch geschnitten ist und jetzt
das ganze einmal aufrollen und dann
zeige ich euch nämlich den trick
[Musik]
wir wollen den tag gibt es einmal nach
innen ein so dass die striche innen sind
und dann erhalten wir eine richtig
schöne blumen optik das gehen wir jetzt
einmal auch unser mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech und geben da auch
noch mal ein sauberes küchentuch drüber
als nächstes kümmere ich mich um die
kartoffel füllung dafür nehme ich mir
jetzt auch wieder ein teig legen und
rollen genauso aus wie grad eben die mit
der schafskäse füllung auch hier nämlich
auch wieder ein erster für der füllung
und verteidigen diesmal aber in die
mitte des teiges als nächstes klappen
wir die beiden enden hier in der mitte
zu und drückten sie auch wieder zusammen
dass auch nichts ausläuft so dann drehen
wir das ganze einmal um also dass die
seite nach unten zeigt und dann ist
unsere nächste füllung auch schon fertig
und so kann man neben unterscheiden
welche füllung in welchen teig drin ist
für die hackfleisch bildung jetzt auch
wieder den teig länglich und etwas breit
ausrollen sowie die anderen beiden eben
auch
[Musik]
ein esslöffel der hackfleisch bildung
hier auf den unteren bereich einmal
verteilen dann wieder zur hälfte
umklappen und feste andrücken
und daraus machen wir es leckere
hörnchen dafür schneiden wir wieder den
teig ein allerdings nicht bis zum ende
also nur ein schneiden und dann wieder
aufrollen nachdem ihr das dann
aufgerollt hat ganz einfach wie ein
hörnchen verbiegen dann ist das hörnchen
auch fertig
[Musik]
und eure befüllten porters müssen jetzt
auf dem backblech abgedeckt mit dem
küchentuch das ist ganz wichtig noch mal
rund 20 bis 30 minuten haltet das bitte
ein und dann werdet ihr richtig schön
fluffige wolken porsche erhalten
[Musik]
der teig durfte jetzt bei mir noch mal
30 minuten unter dem tuch gehen ich habe
in der zwischenzeit auch schon das
zweite blech fertig gemacht also die
zweite hälfte und ich habe einfach jede
menge füllung übrig denn ich hab gleich
vor noch mehr zu backen aber für euch
habe ich jetzt die mengenangaben für ein
kilogramm mehl aufgeschrieben oder ich
schreibe euch auch jedes mal die füllung
auf die für ein kilogramm mehl also für
diesen tag dann ausreicht jetzt geht es
weiter will bestreichen unsere
teilnehmer jetzt noch mit eigelb und
milch das verkehrlich jetzt und dann
zeige ich euch noch die dekoration
[Musik]
die fertig bestrichenen porters werden
jetzt noch dekoriert das ist ganz
wichtig und verzichtet auch nicht drauf
ihr bekommen dass in jedem türkischen
supermarkt und zwar schwarzkümmel ihr
könnt dann auch sehen dann dazu geben
entweder umgerüsteten dann rüstet das
ganze im ofen oder ein der bereits
gerüstet ist
[Musik]
und jetzt kommen die potters in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für ca 20 bis 23 minuten
schaut einfach dass sie richtig schön
gold frauen sind so meine botschaft sind
fertig die zweite ladung besitzen
backofen ganze 20 minuten hat es bei mir
gedauert und wenn ihr sie nach dem
backen direkt mit einem geschirrtuch
abdeckt dann bleiben sie auch richtig
schön soft und jetzt zeige ich euch mal
wie weit die sind so sehen sie aus als
sie dann richtig schön groß wendet sie
genauso groß macht sich das heißt 70
gramm pro kugel dann bekommt ebenso
große potters raus und insgesamt 24
stück in der anzahl von den öffnen wir
jetzt sofort
guck mal wie weit das ist richtig zoff
[Musik]
und genau deshalb habe ich mich für drei
verschiedene formen entschieden so weiß
jeder in welcher form sich welche
füllung versteckt meinte hoffen
was magst du nicht wirklich weiß was da
drin ist okay und jetzt weißt du es
dafür gewissheit keine bösen
überraschungen obwohl die überraschung
sind alle nicht böse mein favorit ist ja
schafskäse
was ist euer favorit haben so was magst
du kartoffeln meine eltern lieben zum
beispiel hackfleisch also für jeden
geschmack was dabei
ich schreibe euch wie immer alles genau
hier unten in der infobox ich freue mich
sehr über eure fotos mit dem hashtag die
sketchen auf instagram ansonsten freue
ich mich auch wenn ich mich hier auf
youtube unterstützt erzählt allen weiter
verteilt den kanal teilt das video ein
dörfchen nach oben und ein kommentar
darüber würde ich mich sehr freuen
und dann sah es bis zum nächsten mal auf
die kiezkicker und wie es jetzt
[Musik]